I won't ask you when you're first having
your conversations about this story are
you talking about it being a Captain
America movie or a Steve Rogers movie
and are they different things or they
bring a different sensibility besides of
it being an Ironman or a Tony Stark
movie is there a difference between the
Steve Rogers movie in a Captain America
film well we've never written the
Captain America movie we've only ever
written for Steve Rogers okay and for
Tony Stark and for all the other people
inside the shells because you know they
get to iconic and stiff if they're if
you're writing for the red white and
blue man you're only gonna write a
patriotic story because that's all he is
on the outside so but Steve is this
90-pound guy from 1943 who's been frozen
and nice and had his friend killed in
front of him and and his material for
much more interesting stories than
Captain America Captain America himself
isn't boring enough guy Steve Rogers
pretty interesting and what about
politics I mean if you look at the first
Captain America movie it clearly is
influenced at least by domestic
surveillance and word Snowden when
you're thinking about the political
ideology of this film are you reacting
as much to what the stories are giving
you as to what's going on in the world
and how do you make sure that you're
integrating the to naturally answer the
most politically minded yes you cannot
make a movie about a character named
Captain America without politics these
are these films have a global reach to
them outside of the u.s. that that that
the title has a specific connotation to
it but I think also because of the genre
that we like to work in IE and we're
soldier is a political thriller on civil
war is a psychological thriller we like
to have the Matic issues that have an
immediacy or a relevancy to the audience
and you know modern issues and I think
that adding a political component to the
character is absolutely necessary
because you know part of his struggle is
an identity question is he Captain
America or is he Steve Rogers
in the first film he you know he's
fighting a very black and white war he's
fighting against the Nazis it's very
clear that there is a there there is
good and there is bad in the second film
which is the Winter Soldier he's
fighting against shield which has been
infiltrated by a bad organization so he
has learned not to trust power
structures in this film he is fighting
against society for his own identity and
and by the end of the film he chooses it
he makes a very personal choice so
politics are intrinsic to who he is as a
character I feel it's important to
dimensionalize him by examining politics
and making sure that the you know that
the that the the issue that he is
dealing with has an immediacy and a
relevancy to it because one of the
things that you're dealing with in this
story is the idea of collateral damage
and collateral damage during wartime and
it's that's a real thing but you also
start by talking about collateral damage
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe
itself which is a little bit strange
that you're kind of poking you're kind
of shining a light at the very end which
you're working what's that something you
settle on very early that you would
actually reference the other movies and
say wait a second in this movie this
entire country seemed to have fallen
down and we didn't deal with what
actually happened absolutely you have to
there's a model to these movies in many
ways right whether it's an origin story
or just a punch up at the end and and I
think Marvel smart enough to break the
model because if you give somebody the
same flavor of ice cream over and over
again they're gonna get sick of it
and so we had all looked at the third
acts and noticed a similarity where
things fall from the sky and ruined
stuff and so we wanted to address that
and and we also wanted to make sure that
so that's why the third act is the third
act it's not we would be absolutely
hypocrites if we did that again so that
we're never going to be at least in our
minds super soldiers to fight and at the
end it was always gonna get deeper and
smaller and more personal and when
you're having a political debate and you
have the character of vision who in
theory is pure why doesn't vision win
the debate and how do you make sure that
vision
isn't the voice of reason that he
doesn't always win every argument and
did you have arguments about whether or
not vision would win I mean that that's
it seems like a trivial question but
it's not about because you have the math
that you have to work I think you that
was basis that's how we spent I think it
was probably like November 2013 just
discussing that very question right
there yeah
it's important when you have characters
are very powerful to make sure that
there is a flaw an internal flaw
psychological flaw to the character if
it's very difficult for an audience to
empathize with somebody who's too
powerful and it's very difficult as as a
creative team and to tell a story where
one character can solve all of the
issues so I think it's that's you know
frankly when I was a kid while I was
attracted to Marvel characters because
there were human and flawed and you know
Tony Stark is an alcoholic and Peter
Parker was a very vulnerable a kid who
was struggling with this incredible
power was also dealing with high school
and and acne and girls and you know it
was what attracted me to them as
characters and I was less interested in
characters who are sort of demigods
because it's hard to tell a story with
those characters that is relatable to to
to a modern audience does that mean you
really find yourself most comfortable
when your characters are out of their
costumes when they're wearing free
clothes without question yeah well I
don't know I I never lose track of the
characters in the costumes it's just
another problem that they have during
their day is that you know now I have to
put on this Iron Man suit and go fly
around it's still still Tony Stark
suffering and the vision is
intrinsically more interesting when he's
cooking
yeah Prakash then what he's fine I mean
that's why he's are beaming exactly I
mean they're those are the two
physically most powerful characters in
this movie mm-hmm they're essentially
magic they have unlimited power and the
fact that I mean they fell in love in
the comics which is a little bit of the
inspiration for it but it also it limits
them in a way where if they were just
wholly on their side with no sympathies
to the other side they would wipe them
out but because they
are developing feelings for each other
which certainly confused vision because
these probably doesn't completely make
sense to him that you know creates a
flaw you know love is there for that
reminder like Paul Bettany one time he
described like the way he he thinks
vision what makes vision tick and he
said that he goes I think vision is just
trying to understand humanity that's
sort of visions purpose so I think that
even though vision is you know Kankan
sort of logic out in any scenario he
wants I think he knows that people don't
always move on logic and I think he's
sort of fascinated with that and that's
part of part of part of his exploration
do you realize in the development of
this story that you don't really have an
exterior villain that the that the
normal way in which a protagonist and
antagonist are created is different in
this story and is that both its
attraction and its problem to solve well
we certainly spent probably a solid
month trying to figure out a story with
that did not have Zemo in it in it we
could not figure out a way to have the
third act we wanted in the way in the
way that we wanted to do it I mean if
Tony was merely the antagonist for Steve
and Steve was merely the antagonist for
Tony
it just wouldn't get to I want to kill
the Winter Soldier in the third act they
might start that way but that's a bummer
of a movie
and and it's probably not fair to Tony's
character well it's also a weird
modulation act that you have to do it
can't be a villain so nefarious that it
undermines the two acts of civil war
you've been watching if if a guy steps
out from behind the curtain and says I'm
actually worse than the fight you've
been having and it's like and then they
shake hands again what were we fighting
about we have to fight him you know it
makes you feel ripped off and we wanted
this conflict to go all the way through
the end of the movie and linger because
it is a there is no right answer to the
fight they're having so we didn't want
the villain to show up and
provide the correct answer to the fight
which is beat that guy up it sounds like
you're making a movie that is in many
ways in reaction to what has gone wrong
on occasion with the genre which is
exactly what you're describing well or
what's Ubiquiti swith exactly what
bumble might be getting tired of right
which is a very traditional structure
which is in the first act you introduce
a hero and a villain and the second act
that come in a conflict and the third
act the hero beats the villain this is a
movie where arguably you could say that
the villain wins the film you know he
has he has the most sort of salient
argument at the end of the movie he's
probably the most empathetic character
outside of jacala and the third act
and and by the time you get to the film
both what Steve and Tony are doing seems
somewhat petty and that's the point of
the movie the point of the movie is to
you know
deconstruct this this this genre and and
to give the audience something that they
weren't expecting that's one thing you
know Joe and I have always liked we've
always worked in like you know it's
trying to subvert genre I think in a lot
of our work we like that and we like we
like the idea that you can you know you
have a there are generic inventions that
were all conditioned to as an audience
and that there's ways that you can
manipulate and play those and sort of
like work against those at certain
moments to create sort of narrative
surprise and excitement I mean this is
like when's the last superhero movie you
saw where the lead of the movie the lead
superhero the movie never actually
physically confronts the villain you
know at the end neither the second lead
Iron Man never confronts the villain
T'Challa
you know Black Panther is the only one
who actually even confront the villain
and all he does is keep the villain from
killing himself you know I'm saying is
very pretty unconventional for some
stuff like a pitch yeah how important
was it to you as well to have three
black superheroes to have Black Panther
war machine and Falcon in one field
unbelievably important I think that it
is an incumbent upon us as creatives I
think it's incumbent upon Hollywood and
it's a little sad that Hollywood is is
is is behind the curve a little bit I
think that as an industry it's so
visible and you
assume that it would be progressive but
I think it is our job making mass
entertainment to keep reflecting what
that means we reflect the you know the
diversity of the audience and so it is
absolutely incumbent upon us to keep
diversifying Christopher Markus Stephen
McFeely Anthony and Joe Russo thank you
guys for bringing us your movie thank
you guys for sticking around with the
qaul for thanks for watching thank you
for doing this